the biggest difference between the all
storytelling and more traditional kinds
of storytelling is that you're not
telling a story in that traditional way
up it's more like home architectural
theme pop design you're creating a place
for people to go rather than kind of
seen them that guy let me tell you a
story
you can put someone in a different world
and they accept that world it can be
hyper stylized it could be realistic
doesn't really change the fact that
you're there and you're experiencing it
it's just this amazing emergent barrier
of game development the technology is
really cool as well on a problem mode so
I just like playing with it this
cutting-edge high-tech stuff I've been
working in games now for about 210 years
making various different kinds of games
over the years and now kind of
specialize in specifically in vail
bethlo games is an independent games
company we are trying to make titles
that are going in a different direction
testing new experiences that's why we're
able to experiment with VRA now the
wheat finish volume and Sony have
started talking to us about you know
what snacks and they started talking to
a spell PlayStation VR I think that's
the big thing is VR is really cool and
there's probably much deeper technical
analysis I could give but it really is
that it's just it's amazing when you put
this stuff on
we are is a huge marketing opportunity
because you can make up the rules as you
go along right now but once I stationed
BR or some of the other companies come
out with their VR platforms we'll get a
better sense of what do people actually
want from this do they want experiences
do they want games do they want films we
have no idea yet what the consumer wants
what we do know though is that all of
the old ways don't really work
necessarily you know you can't look at a
trailer and get a real experience of
what that games going to be you can't
watch a streamer or YouTube or playing a
game and get a real sense of what that
game is we're gonna have to go out and
show players what these games are put
the games in people's hands you know
it's always very very weak to say the
target audiences everyone but that could
be the way we're going in the same way
as who's the target audience for
television I do think there is an
opportunity there for now
yes but now the audience who are playing
VR or super engaged tech people who want
cool awesome new technologies to play
with what's very interesting with VR is
the tangibility of these worlds in the
sense they feel like real places is that
means that you can actually incorporate
much more tangible ways of marketing
when you think about VR tourism most
people will think like ah you know I'm
gonna be on a beach and it's gonna be
beautiful but that doesn't have to be
yet it could be a game it could just be
a really beautiful environment and again
and you just take time there you just
sit there and you look around
we are literally looks you in and you
you can't experience other stuff while
you're in it even with something that's
not realistic something that's more kind
of abstract or stylized you remember it
in the same way as you learn the places
that kind of sense of presence like how
it felt to be there how you got there
what the environment was like how it
sounded how it looks it's not like
remembering an image or a screen the
future were just getting a gluts at a
train and if VR is picked up we're going
to be shocked by how extremely fast
technology moves after that in giving
different experiences on different
platforms
I feel like VR is going to have an
impact it's going to be a thing whether
it takes over whether we're all losing
our TVs in two years I don't know but
it's it's gonna happen in fact it's
gonna have an impact so I think there is
definitely great work to be done there
and which is having a great time